Merhaba sevgili öğrenciler. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. Bu dersimizde 9. sınıfın 8.
ünitesi olan Life in the Universe
Feature yani evrende gelecekte yaşam
adlı üniteyi hep birlikte işleyeceğiz.
Eğer bu ünite ile ilgili alıştırmalar,
testler, denemeler çözmek istiyorsanız,
öğrendiğiniz kelimeleri oyunlarla
pekiştirmek istiyorsanız Play Store ve
App Store'dan Justin Academ uygulamasını
ücretsiz bir şekilde indirip
kullanabilirsiniz. Kalem ve kağıdınız
hazırsa dersimiz başlıyor. Dersimizi
film türlerinin İngilizce isimlerini
öğrenmekle başlayalım. Film Canas, Film
türleri, Musical, Musical,
Martial Art, Dövüş Sanatları
Space Adventure Uzay Macerası,
Historical, Tarihi,
Biographical,
Biographic, Alien Invasion, Uzaylı
istilası
detective, detektif
Documentary
belgesel
adventure macera
cartoon çizki film
comedy comedy
family aile mystery gizem
romantik romantik
science fiction bilim kurgu
thriller gerilim
time travel
Zamanda seyahat. Film türlerinin
İngilizce isimlerini bitirdik. Şimdi
filmlerle ilgili terimler var.
Robot,
robot. Zombi. Zombi.
Klone. Klon.
Yani genetik yapısı birbirine tıpatıp
aynı olan canlı topluluğu.
Wormhall solucan deliği. Spice
exploration uzay keşfi. Artificial
intelligent. Yapay zeka,
virtual reality.
Sanal gerçeklik.
Technological.
Teknolojik.
Sırada filmlerle ilgili kelimeler var.
Crew,
ekip.
Actris, kadın oyuncu,
actor, erkek oyuncu.
Director, yönetmen.
Superhero, süper kahraman.
Bu ünitede bulunan bilmeniz gereken
diğer önemli kelimeler şunlardır.
Adapt adapte etmek. Control kontrol
etmek. Invad istila etmek.
Explore keşfetmek.
Save korumak. Survive hayatta kalmak.
Discover keşfetmek.
Invent icat etmek.
Direct yönetmek.
Social language sosyal dil demektir. Bu
ünitede günlük hayatta
kullanabileceğimiz ifadeler şunlardır.
This film is a breath of fresh air. Bu
film temiz bir nefes gibi. Bu film bana
çok iyi geldi anlamlarına gelir. This
film is not my cup of tea. Bu film hiç
bana göre değil. Benim tarzım değil.
Demek istiyorsanız da bu ifadeyi
kullanabilirsiniz. Not my cup of tea. I
not brave enough to watch this. Bunu
izleyecek kadar cesur değilim. What's
next? Sırada ne var? Şimdi ne izliyoruz
gibi anlamlara gelir. İngilizcede en çok
kullanılan, günlük hayatta sürekli
karşınıza çıkacak olan en basit, en
kolay ama en temel konulardan bir tanesi
olan feature tense kalıplarından will
konusunu işleyeceğiz.
Feature tense yani gelecek zaman
demektir. Biz gelecekten bahsederken bu
zamanı kullanırız. Bu zamanda birkaç
tane kalıp vardır ama bunlardan ilki
will kalıbıdır. Will Türkçede cümlelere
ecek acak anlamı katar. Planlanmamış
konuşma anında verilen kararları ifade
etmek için kullanılır. Mesela
arkadaşlarınızla oturuyorsunuz canınız
sıkıldı. Hadi dışarı çıkalım. Biz dışarı
çıkacağız. Bu tarz konuşma esnasında
karar verdiğiniz, önceden
planlamadığınız durumlardan bahsederken
fiil yapısını kullanabilirsiniz.
Gelecekte olan olaylar hakkında tahminde
bulunma, zannetme, ümit etme, endişe
etme gibi durumlar da kullanılır. Umarım
gelecekte böyle olacak. Tahminime göre
şunlar gerçekleşecek tarzı söylemlerde
de will kullanırız. Ayrıca future tense
karşı tarafa bir şey teklif ederken de
kullanılan yapılardan bir tanesidir.
Kullanımı oldukça kolay. Örneklerle
pekiştireceğiz. Ve siz bu konuyu daha
iyi anlayacaksınız. Positive form olumlu
hal demektir. Eğer will yapısını
kullanarak gelecek zamanda olumlu cümle
oluşturmak istiyorsak cümle yapıları şu
şekilde olacak. Cümleye her zaman bir
özne ile başlarız.
Ben, sen ya da siz. We, biz, they,
onlar. He erkekler için kullanılır, o
demektir. She kızlar için kullanılır, o
demektir. It cansız ve hayvanlarda
kullanılır, o demektir. Bütün bu
öznelerden sonra will yapısı hiç
değişmeden olduğu haliyle kullanılır ve
will'den sonra yine fiili hiç değişmeden
birinci haliyle kullanırız. Bu yüzden
bunu kullanmak oldukça kolay. Will
kelimesini kısa bir halde de
yazabiliriz. Öznelerden sonra kesme
işareti kullanıp iki tane L harfi
yazarsak will yapısını kısaltmış oluruz.
Örnekleri inceleyelim ve daha iyi
anlayın. I will call a taxi for you.
Senin için bir taksi arayacağım. Ay ben
demektir. Hiçbir özne değişmez. Gelecek
zaman anlamı katmak istiyorsak will
kullanacağız. Will'den sonra fiilin
birinci hali kullanılır. Konuşma
esnasında gelecekten bahsedeceksek ani
verilen kararlarda bu yapıyı
kullanabiliriz. Şeyma will eat two
hamburgers. Şeyma iki tane hamburger
yiyecek. Şeyma kızdır. Kız özelerinden
sonra will yapısı yine değişmez.
Will'den sonra da fiilin birinci halini
kullanırız. Hamza will watch cartoons.
Hamza çizgi film izleyecek. Hamza'dan
sonra will yapısını kullanırız. Daha
sonra fiilin birinci halini yanına
ekleriz. I think they will win the race.
Bence onlar yarışı kazanacaklar. Bence
sanırım umarım tarzı gelecek hakkında
tahmin, endişe ya da bir çıkarımda
bulunuyorsak will yapısını kullanacağız.
They öznesinden sonra will yazar. Fiilin
birinci halini yanına ekleriz. We will
make some sandwiches. Biz biraz sandwich
yapacağız. Gördüğünüz gibi we biz
öznesidir. Ondan sonra will kullandık.
Daha sonra fiilin birinci halini yanına
ekledik. Negative form olumsuz hal
demektir. Eğer will yapısını kullanarak
gelecekle ilgili olumsuz bir durumdan
bahsedeceksek cümle yapısı şu şekilde
olmalıdır. Cümleye yine bir özne ile
başlayacağız. Özneleri seçtikten sonra
willin olumsuz hali olan want'u
kullanacağız. Bundan sonra yine fiilin
birinci hali geliyor. Yani fiile
karışmıyoruz.
W kelimesi aslında will not şeklinde
olumsuz yazılır ama genelde bu uzun
halidir. Böyle tercih edilmez. Kısacası
want yazılır. Örnekleri inceleyelim. I
want drink milk. Ben süt içmeyeceğim. I
özesinden sonra olumsuzluk anlamı katan
want kullandık. Daha sonra fiilin
birinci halini yanına yazdık. He want by
a new car. O yeni araba satın almayacak.
He özesinden sonra olumsuzluk yapan
want'u kullandık. She won't read that
novel. O bu romanı okumayacak. She
öznesinden sonra gelecek zamanda olumsuz
yaparken won't kullanacağız. We want go
to the bank. Biz bankaya gitmeyeceğiz.
Böyle bir ihtiyacımız yok. Gitmeyeceğiz.
Gelecek zamanın olumsuz hali wantu
kullanırız. They won't join a party.
Onlar cadılar bayramına katılmayacaklar.
They özesinden sonra olumsuz hali olanu
kullanacağız. Question form soru hali
demektir. Gelecekle ilgili eğer soru
sormak istiyorsak yapacak mısın, olacak
mı tarzı evet hayır sorularını şu
şekilde oluştururuz. Bu sefer özne ile
will yer değiştirecek. Will'i başta
kullanacağız. Daha sonra öznelerden bir
tanesini yazıp fiilin birinci halini
kullanıp soru işareti ekleyeceğiz.
Gördüğünüz gibi oldukça kolay iki taraf
yer değiştirecek. Örnekleri inceleyelim.
Will you cook dinner? Sen akşam yemeği
pişirecek misin? soru olduğu için will
cümlenin başına geldi. Eğer pişirecekse
yes will. Eğer pişirmeyecekse no
diyeceğiz. Will she attend the meeting o
toplantıya katılacak mı? Soru olduğu
için will başta oldu. Daha sonra özneyi
yazdık. Eğer katılacaksa yes she will
ama eğer katılmayacaksa no she won't
diyeceğiz. Time expression zaman
ifadeleri demektir. Gelecek zamanda
kullanılan zaman ifadelerine bakalım.
Next kelimesini kullanabiliriz. Sonraki
gelecekteki anlamına gelir. Örneğin next
week, next year, next month, gelecek
hafta, gelecek yıl, gelecek ay gibi.
Tomorrow yarın demektir. Cümlelerde
genellikle bu ifadeyi görürüz. In the
future gelecekte, soon, yakınlarda.
Later sonra mesela iki gün sonra, 2
hafta sonra. Tonight bu gece demektir.
Bunlar da gelecek zamandan bahsederken
kullandığımız ifadelerdir. They will
play tennis later. Onlar daha sonra
tenis oynayacaklar. Gördüğünüz gibi
zaman ifadeleri genellikle cümlenin
sonunda tercih edilir. They özesinden
sonra gelecek anlamı katan will
kullandık. I will buy a house soon. Ben
yakında bir ev satın alacağım. I
özesinden sonra will kullandık. Yakında
kelimesi olan so'u cümlenin sonunda
belirttik. Important expressions. Önemli
ifadeler. Dersi anlatırken en başta
belirt. Eğer gelecekle ilgili bir
tahminden, bir düşüncemizden
bahsedeceksek bunlarda da will
kullanabiliriz. Mesela cümle I think ile
başlıyorsa bence demektir. I believe
inanıyorum. I hope umarım. I sure
eminim. I afraid korkarım. Probably
muhtemelen. Bu tarz ifadelerden sonra
kuracağımız cümlede will kelimesini
kullanacağız. Örneğin I hope you will be
a rich man in the future. Um gelecekte
sen zengin bir adam olursun. I hope.
Umarım demektir. Bu yapıdan sonraki
cümlede will kullanırız. I sure she
will help me. Eminim o bana yardım
edecek. I sure ifadesinden sonra will
kullanırız. Beni dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür ederim. Play Store ve App
Store'dan Justin Academy uygulamasını
indirip kullanmayı unutmayın lütfen. H